[Música]
tal vez hayas visto este símbolo antes
en un tatuaje o en un templo chino es el
símbolo del yin y el yang viene del
taoísmo una religión nacida en China y
significa mucho más de lo que crees
El yin es la voluta oscura y el yang la
Clara y cada lado tiene un punto del
color opuesto que nos da una pista de su
significado todo contiene la semilla de
su opuesto
Darth vader tiene la semilla del bien y
Luke puede seguir a su padre al lado
oscuro
al igual que Luke y su padre el yin y el
yang no son Opuestos totales son
relativos el uno al otro los taoístas
creen que el universo está compuesto de
energías vibraciones y sustancia que se
comportan de diferentes maneras según el
contexto algo puede ser Jean o yang
según muchas cosas
así Mientras que el trigo que crece es
yang cuando se cosecha es yin
la cresta de una ola es yang y el seno
es el yin
las aldeas del lado soleado de un valle
en China tienen nombres como lujo yang o
shang pero del lado con sombra como en
el Valle del río llancé está
el freno es el yin y el acelerador el
yang
la cáscara del huevo es el yang y el
interior del huevo es el jean crees
estar entendiendo el yang es más duro
fuerte brillante y más rápido pero uno
se puede convertir en el otro o son las
dos caras de la misma moneda
los rayos del sol son young en
comparación a las sombras
lanzar la pelota es young agarrar la
pelota es Jean el yang empieza una
acción y el yin la recibe la termina
el yin es el espacio interior de una
taza no sería una taza sin él yang es la
tasa el calor del café sin embargo es el
yang y su negrura es el yin el yang se
vuelve loco a veces pero también hay
algunos jeans poderosos si es que no
llegan a volverse locos el yin es el
remolino más oscuro femenino pero
contiene un punto blanco y el yang es el
claro masculino pero contiene un punto
negro
el agua que fluye con calma en un río es
el yin pero cuando llega a la cascada es
muy yang los palillos son Jean
comparados a un poste
la parte trasera de una persona es más
Jean que el frente y la parte superior
es el fin del yang el taoísmo afirma que
hay un poder en el universo
es más elevado profundo y verdadero que
cualquier otro le llaman Tao significa
el camino igual que la fuerza en la
guerra de las Galaxias El tao tiene dos
caras A diferencia de otras religiones
donde el poder superior es bueno Y quizá
tiene un rival malo el taoísmo enseña
que tenemos que aprender del yin y del
yang A diferencia de las religiones con
dioses personales el poder superior en
el taoísmo no lo es
los taoístas creen que si vive en
armonía con el camino una persona no
tendrá que luchar contra el flujo
natural del universo
así por ejemplo si escuchas más discutes
menos Y estás preparado para retroceder
o reparar algo podrás avanzar aún más
rápido No te preocupes en ser el mejor
sé quién eres
vive simple las complicaciones te alejan
del tao
el sabio es flexible dicen los taoístas
Aprender a usar el Tao de eso se trata
el taoísmo y por eso debes conocer tu
yin a partir de tu yang
todavía está buscando una filosofía que
repercuta en usted Explore la antigua
filosofía grecorromana del estoicismo
con este video Y descubra si el estilo
de vida estoico es algo que valga la
pena seguir
[Música]